if your game could vote for whatever to
remain or leave in the EU this is versus
the GameSpot show that pits your
favorite games consoles franchises and
hot-button topics against each other
this week its overwatch versus Rainbow
six siege two esteemed members of the
GameSpot team are going to be debating
these games out and then you get to
decide who wins batting for overwatch is
tomorrow who saying whose love for the
game is so strong he has a picture of
Jeff from the overwatch team on his
phone case which I'm sure mr. Caplin is
totally fine with and arguing for siege
is the UK team's resident trashmouth
Oscar Deus Oscar is a siege superfan
just look at him here with his hat and
his mug shame that mug was a Secret
Santa present from tomorrow who well
designed it each are going to argue the
corner for their game over the course of
three randomly picked topics with the
overall winner being decided by you the
viewers we're going to be chucking up a
clickable poll right up here on YouTube
or if you're watching over on GameSpot
calm let us know who you think has won
the debate in the comment section below
right let's get into it
[Music]
damn Oscar you ready for me to test your
chin with my fist and also your debating
skills not with my fist fist looks very
small we're gonna be putting quitting
putting putting Rainbow six siege versus
elite game over watch which terrible
game I don't I don't want to overstate
how much better overwatch is because it
would be unbecoming and it's not very
classy so I'm just gonna we're gonna I'm
gonna talk it through I'm gonna be the
bigger man here right I step in I'm
bored of hearing you talk so modes well
bat which game has the best modes
I mean clearly that's C because C to
better man watch it pretty much
everything there are three main modes in
the PvP in siege there's hostage as bomb
secure area square is your default one
it's pretty basic I'm not gonna lie it's
like one person gets in in person ice to
hold it whatever form it's basically the
same but spread over two rooms this is
about kind of spreads you out it's a
little bit more interesting you have to
think about where placing your traps a
little bit more and then hostage I think
is like kind of turns the game on its
head because you suddenly have to think
about getting into the room but not
being too destructive because if you if
you are then you might kill the hostage
then also you've got sieges PvE modes
like outbreak is on at the moment
outbreak is like a really cool it
zombies alien mode that's like zombies
in coordinating but better yeah I think
siege wins this one hands down should we
move on no I think that sounded like a
lot of modes from a lot of first-person
shooters which is a problem that most
first-person shooter compared everyone's
face so I think all watch wins in terms
of variety and allowing you to do more
it's got the basic modes the three you
know capture the point secure a point
and then the other one is a payload one
where you move it from one side of the
map to the other where overwatch really
kind of sets itself apart from games
like siege and other ones is it affords
you the freedom to play in various
different ways so you can play those
standard modes in casual and compare but
then you go into the arcade and arcade
is all about just fire finding fun modes
to play with so it brings in seasonal
modes like oh the loose your ball for
example which is effectively a take on
rocket League using lucile's and then
you have
other ones which are like wave based
ones like Junkin Stein's revenge that's
another seasonal thing where it was like
you've got this giant gate and you've
got waves of enemies coming at you but
if you want to have just a cool fun time
and just do something else and kind of
cleanse your palate you've got so many
options available to you so I think I've
very comprehensively proved there but a
voyage has a selection of modes so to me
it sounds like arcade is essentially
like a dumping ground for old modes
right it's like you've clearly just
skewed the language they have just
passionately I passionately explained
why it would provide such great options
to people and then is tried there of a
little bit of evil tongue behavior it's
been like I mean the press main dump is
been dr. okay let's call it taste a
dumping mode they're dumping dumping
like a dumping ground for cleanup over
TV news platoon what's the thing they
called the weekly splatfest yeah you're
in versus feces I mean you could order a
dumping ground if you want at least it
has enough monster dump I mean that's a
fair point that's a fair point but it
sounds to me like the I mean overwatch
and siege of both games that are
constantly evolving changing right hmm
an old mode surely it's no longer
relevant the game would have moved on I
don't want to go back to an old mode
when I know when the game is complete
you're very severely limiting siege is
like they they tailor the game precisely
to those three modes and they stick with
them you've basically argued that a game
that has more modes isn't as good
because it's got more modest as if those
modes are not good I just not fun to
play then why would I want to play them
this is a very bad argument because
you're saying like we're not oh you're
assuming that they're bad they're not
bad they've been moved because they're
not relevant to the the game as it is
that makes you think all right so the
next topic we're going to be debating is
shooting so I think where overwatch has
the advantage over siege is the spread
of the types of shooting experience that
you get out of it it spans the legacy of
shooters so you've got everything from
the classics doom quake style shooter
Farra is a character therefore you who
is able to use like rocket jumps and
that kind of business so you've you're
familiar with that if you're a recent
player who likes like Call of Duty or
where that maybe battlefield you have
soldier like he's got the sprint from
those types of games and his shooting
feels very much like a Call of Duty
games and then you've got more like
crazier types of players and characters
you have like mercy who's a healer but
is like capable of getting flying around
you've got a DeVos a tank but she's in a
mech and so she can fly around and fire
rockets and she's boys and AMEX it's
just the legacy of shooters all wrapped
up into one game and because of that you
get such a good kind of like range of
textures and feel of playing in that
game there's always there's there's a
shooter experience in there for everyone
I think the same is true of siege but I
think the best thing about see just
shooting is that it's a game that if you
if a Ryan goes perfectly you shouldn't
need to shoot you should really be using
your abilities in the environment your
advantage so for example if you're on
the defensive side then you've got
Capcom and loads of other trap operators
like realistically you're never gonna go
a whole reign without shooting again but
you should be able to Thea Knight the
attacking team before they get there and
even on the attacking team you've got
like operators that when they do have to
shoot it's really really satisfying so
for example buff has got an assault
rifle that when you press right bumper
or r1 it changes into a shotgun but then
you've also got operators like sledge
who comes with a massive sledgehammer
and he can just knock down water but
like I say you've got you've got
operators like glass as well here he has
a massive sniper rifle that has a
thermal scope and that's really
satisfying to use in it like you can
feel the kick in the controller when you
use that and it's so satisfying and like
the problem I have with overwatch is
shooting is that like I've played over
what I've tried to get into it but it
just doesn't feel satisfying when when
you're clicking that mouse oh when
you're pulling the trigger it just
doesn't feel satisfying I feel like I'm
like firing a spud gun
jimena there's no weight to any of the
shooting I don't feel like I'm feeling
any damage to the opponent I mean it
depends on who you play like everyone
has a different feel to them I think
everyone in that game has got heft and
weight and feel satisfying soldier he's
the feeling of his gun is so good you
can
feel like every - every bullet that hits
him like you can feel they're kind of
chipping away at their energy just
because of the sound effects they use
when you hit them and his alt which is
like a visor that automatically for a
very short window will kind of highlight
everyone and shoot just for you for a
bit
Wow so you hang on you're saying the
best operator a character hero wherever
they're called in overwatch is the one
that feels like it's satisfying to shoot
with and also lets you see where
everyone is on the map and shoots for
you know that I specifically didn't say
that I said that was one of the cases
that feelgood's areas for example as a
character that fires balls from a
distance and she can her splash damage
that you get out of it feels really
satisfying like again it feels like play
now can I ping a headshot from across
the map and see the blood spatter on the
wall behind them you know you are you
are paying yourself as the archetypal
dude bro now can I pin someone in the ED
and see some blood actly
balls maps brackets level design
I think C's wins this hands down because
the maps are always changing and I mean
that both on a micro level of you might
play as sledge and you might knock a
massive hole for a wall so the map is
always changing on that aspect and also
on the defensive side as well you can
set up traps that completely changed the
dynamic of which doorways you can go
through and the choke points that you
can funnel your enemies into also if you
play ranks you can choose where you
spawn and where and that goes for the
defensive side as well you can choose
where the objective room spawns to and
so that completely changes the kind of
strategies that you that you're gonna
employ because you might be on a top
floor and therefore you don't need to
worry about the floor above you then
also they're actually changing the maps
themselves so there's a buff coming up
for clubhouse which they're adding like
a room between the money room and
bedroom so that's going to complete and
like that's a really common attacking
point at the moment so you're gonna have
to completely like switch up the way you
attack on that map and the way you
defend sieges biggest strength with its
Maps is how everything is changing both
on a micro level and on a macro
so what your favorite maps in that game
I really like Bank I really like house
like it doesn't suit the matter but it
feels like games are so frantic and it's
like very reactionary and I really like
much is on there okay so that basically
speaks to why I think a watch is more
interesting in terms of maps that what
you've just said there
it's like indicative of why I don't like
the maps in in siege you like Bank house
just the absence of any sort of
personality the absence of any sort of
interest if that's the best they can do
to name their Maps just imagine how I
know how boring it is to be in them and
and like there's such generic areas
whereas over what has got this flair to
everything that's what it's about it's
just about capturing your imagination
like illios of all skya industries
junker town these are like evocative
names and they're evocative places to be
in John Curtin's this kind of like Mad
Max kind of weird area that's owned by a
crazy gang of treasure hunters so it's
like really interesting to look at and
Valle skaia industries like you look at
and you're like I understand from this
like you build there's loll I just laced
into every aspect of each map of that
game and all other maps don't change
they're constantly giving you new things
to think about
I really like the idea of a fully
destructible map that's really
interesting to me but the problem I have
it weather is everywhere you look it's
just a bit plain over watches Maps
I have posters of them and I'm like
proud to display them grow up for a
sudden flame if you put a poster of a
siege map anywhere you just be like oh
it looks just like every other map in
every other game your entire argument is
built upon the fact that overwatch is
maps look not really interesting and
have interesting names no I literally
explained there was a whole sermon if
you rewind a bit Ryan the tapes guys if
you're on YouTube just hit back a bit
sneak back a bit computer now there was
nothing about the dynamism of each map
is casually being forgotten by this
classic Rainbow six siege players you
like
or what you're talking about on my game
yeah it's the problem with Rainbow six
these players their game is good now and
they've got a bit of a chip on their
shoulder now they're like yeah really
nice
all right enough smack talk from those
two let us know your thoughts on who won
the debate by voting in the above poll
or if you're over on GameSpot calm by
chucking your thoughts in the comment
section below of course it will be your
boats that decide who wins okay before
we round out the show we've got the
quick fire round a series of dumb
questions written by the rest of the UK
team naturally Oscar and two more
haven't seen any of these so this will
be fun
the own impression of your favorite gun
if we were gonna yeah favorite my
favorite gotta go sorry as beam chemical
beam cannon I'll do Caputo's bone arrow
that was like a fire downward trajectory
well you never kill anyone if your game
could vote whatever vote to remain or
leave in the EU
what is a team-based objective game it's
critical that you work together
thus it all vote to remain in the EU I
think siege and this is no comment on
either my or the games or Ubisoft
political beliefs but I reckon siege
would have voted to leave because it's
all about like hard borders and it and
like putting up barricades yeah do an
impression of a character from the
opposite game oh I've got a gun I look
like that guy who looks like that guy
who looks like that guy oh I've got a
gun but it doesn't do anything
I mean look like that guy from fortnight
and that guy from fortnight and that guy
for tonight let you bring rain to it if
your game was a car what would it be oh
that is an interesting question it's
interesting because don't know anything
about cars siege would be Bugatti Veyron
per hour mine would be a bumper car just
jump in it slamming tell people have a
good time at the fun
it's great time Clank are right
questions that's a wrap remember to get
your voice heard in our poll or in the
comment section below and tell us who
you think argued their case better and
if you enjoyed this episode of versus
make sure to hit that subscribe button
as we'll have new episodes of the show
every Wednesday thanks for watching Bay
[Music]
you